[Musique]
nous voilà de retour pour un nouveau
numéro de paris saclay tv bienvenus être
étudiant et entrepreneurs non seulement
c'est possible mais c'est devenu une
évidence sur votre territoire
nous reviendrons sur la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant
elle a eu lieu ici même à l'instar paris
tech
il entame un tour de france tlf for good
veut sensibiliser à l'innovation
technologique au service de tous le coup
d'envoi de cette initiative a eu lieu au
proto 204 et justement nous verrons
comment la technologie permet de
contribuer à la création du learning
center qui se construit à paris
s'atteler ces futurs usagers peuvent
donner leur avis grâce à la réalité et
virtuel
enfin nous vous emmènerons sur un campus
un campus des services de l'automobile
et de la mobilité
douze mille mètres carrés pour se former
auto moto vélo tous les domaines sont
couverts notre agenda ce sera à la fin
de cette émission vous saurez tout sur
les événements à venir
[Musique]
on commence donc cette émission avec la
journée entrepreneuriat étudiant c'est
devenu un événement incontournable de
votre territoire
c'est l'occasion pour ces étudiants
entrepreneurs de venir défendre leurs
projets de les présenter aussi
aujourd'hui tout est fait pour que les
jeunes prennent cette voie nous avons
assisté à cette journée qui a eu lieu
ici
à l'instar paristech
la journée de l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
est un événement majeur pour l'ensemble
des établissements du sud francilien
pour à la fois présenter les projets
portés par des étudiants mais également
pour faire en sorte que les étudiants
qui ne sont pas ou qui n'ont pas d'idées
ou qui ne sont pas encore entrepreneurs
puissent ou souhaitent le devenir
oui envie de le devenir nous rassemblons
ici environ 70 projets qui participent à
la fois un concours de pitch mais
également un salon c'est une occasion
pour ces étudiants de tester leurs idées
de les présenter un écosystème
professionnels de faire en sorte
d'accélérer le développement de ses
projets et pourquoi pas un jour faire en
sorte que ces projets aboutissent à une
un service ou un produit concret qui
inondent le marché
l'idée c'est vraiment de regrouper la
communauté d'exposer les projets de
faire des contacts avec des entreprises
et des investisseurs mais également de
sensibiliser les futurs étudiants
entrepreneurs donc la nouveauté c'est on
a amené en fait 150 étudiants issus des
universités d'evry et puis panthéon pour
être au contact de ces projets est menée
sur tout un programme learning by doing
donc apprendre en faisant être vraiment
au contact des pitchs commencé à
comprendre les postures des
entrepreneurs noté et discuter avec des
professeurs sur place des projets donc
c'est vraiment un programme super actif
parce qu'on est très consciente la
sensibilisation au coeur de la
sensibilisation il ya tous les enjeux
des entrepreneurs de demain
donc si on forme les étudiants
entrepreneurs aujourd'hui ensuite on a
des entrepreneurs qui s'empare des
projets et qui créent leur entreprise
trois quatre ans plus tard et qui
rentrent en tant que étudiants
entrepreneurs et qui suivent également
notre diplôme est une et entrepreneurs
de paris saclay pour nous la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant
c'est un événement incontournable sur le
territoire je pense que c'est un lieu
de veille économique concurrentiel qui
est très pertinent pour les entreprises
en fait ce sont des entrepreneurs
aguerris qui vont donner leur vision à
des jeunes entrepreneurs
et ça il n'y a jamais rien de plus
riches j'incite toutes les entreprises à
participer à ce type d'événement parce
que je suis persuadé que le lien entre
ces jeunes entreprises naissantes et les
anciennes créeront demain de la valeur
pour le développement économique et pour
l'emploi du territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la technologie oui mais pas à n'importe
quel prix c'est le credo des
organisateurs de take for good
ils défendent une innovation pour le
bien de tous une low tech humaniste il
se lance dans un grand tour de france
pour nous sensibiliser et le coup
d'envoi de cette opération a eu lieu sur
votre territoire au proto 204
[Musique]
ce soir on est ici pour le lancement du
territoire brutaux 2019 ce secteur
bhutto en fait c'est l'occasion pour
nous de sensibiliser à l'innovation
technologique au service du bien commun
donc on fait le lancement en proto 204
sur le plateau de saclay qui est la
première ville de notre tour de france
toujours ce qui nous attend c'est une
table ronde qui viendra questionner un
peu le rôle de différentes technologies
dans la résolution des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux d'aujourd'hui et
ensuite on va passer du temps à soutenir
ou à créer des projets take for good
donc il s'inscrit vraiment dans cette
dynamique de l'utilisation de la
technologie pour avoir un impact positif
que ce soit en lien avec le combat face
au réchauffement climatique
vaincre le cancer aider les personnes
sans domicile par rapport à leur
situation
toutes les thématiques qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui pour la société on aura des
pics ou d'entrepreneurs qui viendront
présenter un peu en inspiration balles
leurs solutions
techpowerup par exemple on a check and
save en tchèque bottes pour pouvoir
apprendre à faire les gestes qui sauvent
ensuite on va passer à une dans une
dynamique qu'on va mettre la main à la
pâte dans différents ateliers pour voir
comme je disais soit créé un projet take
for good soit soutenir des projets
existants donc par exemple ce soir sur
la table ronde
on attend qu'il vient du low tech lab
donc ils cherchent vraiment référence et
un maximum de d'innovation qui demande
peu de technique peu technologie et ils
les mettent à disposition d'un maximum
de monde ont fait flotter club s'est
développée diffuser et promouvoir des
lots technologie donc la technologie
qu'est ce que c'est c'est des solutions
techniques simples utiles durable
accessible qui si elles étaient répliqué
à grande échelle pourrait répondre aux
besoins de base du plus grand nombre et
on estime que
finalement résoudre un problème sociétal
environnemental par de la tech c'est
bien ce qu'ils attaquent et pas elle
même un problème sociétal et
environnemental
on a fait des riques de l'audace qui
créent des outils numériques au service
de structures d'intérêt général du qui
viennent du monde de l'urss et on à
vincent qui vient du design spot qui est
un peu un lieu clé pour les étudiants et
chercheurs en design à saclay juste
après ça on enchaînera sur un cocktail
parce qu'en fait ce soir on a plein de
personnes de profils variés dont l'idée
c'est vraiment faire du lien entre les
personnes qui sont à la fois actrice de
l'innovation sociale et les personnes y
sont avec ces deux innovations
technologiques du qu'on profite de ce
soir un peu comme une plateforme pour
pouvoir faire du lien dans cet
écosystème qui est un peu disparate
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres de cette
démarche take for good votre territoire
va bientôt accueillir un learning center
un lieu dédié à l'écrit à la lecture est
bien pour que ce lieu soit le plus
adapté aux attentes des usagers
ils sont invités à le tester
virtuellement ses ateliers organisés par
l'université paris saclay ont lieu ici
au laboratoire limsi nous avons
rencontré julien sempéré chef de projet
e learning center
[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui aux lignes 6 qui
est un des laboratoires demi-heure t
paris saclay sous tutelle du cnrs et ce
laboratoire est notamment spécialisée en
réalité virtuelle réalité augmentée et
dans le cadre du projet learning center
double learning center c'est un bâtiment
qui va être ouvert à tous les publics
donc à tous les citoyens et qui
développe des activités événementielles
autour du livre de l'écrit de la lecture
qui va travailler aussi à la médiation
scientifique à l'innovation pédagogique
et au design et ce lieu qui est donc
l'union de plusieurs bibliothèques
universitaires sur le plateau de moulon
est un lieu qui va ouvrir ses portes
d'ici un an et demi environ
donc dans le cadre du projet nous avons
évidemment besoin
petit à petit de mettre en place les
espaces et les services et nous
profitons du fait d'avoir une maquette
numérique du bâtiment en cours de
conception pour pouvoir travailler en
réalité virtuelle c'est à dire que avec
des usages et donc des étudiants des
professeurs avec des collègues
professionnels de la médiation
scientifique de l'innovation pédagogique
des bibliothèques
nous nous réunissons toutes les semaines
pour travailler sur les différents
espaces du lieu et les aménager donc en
lien avec la maîtrise d'oeuvre
l'architecte
nous travaillons l'aménagement de ce
lieu en nous concentrant sur les usages
et les normes apport du leem si de
l'équipe venise du leem si cette
capacité à collaborer en réalité
virtuelle c'est à dire que nous sommes à
l'intérieur du bâtiment aménagé tel que
nous l'avons imaginé tel que nous en
discutons et nous testons nos idées nous
les abandons et nous nous retrouvons
régulièrement pour revoir un peu les
détails extra avant de faire les marchés
d'aménagement mobilier donc partir des
besoins des publics partir de leurs
façons de réagir partir des services que
nous allons fournir pour imaginer
comment nous aménageons les lieux nous
paraissait une très bonne approche et
c'est aussi un projet qui nous permet de
nous rapprocher de nos voisins et le
leem ci sera notamment laboratoire très
proche dynamique center et ça nous
permet de commencer à créer des
collaborations puisqu'on touche eu
également à la recherche puisque des
kills the nice
s'intéresse à la collaboration réalité
virtuelle qu'est ce que ça nous apporte
comment on travaille mieux dans ces
conditions ainsi on est à la fois les
utilisateurs de cette technologie mais
aussi quelque part au sens positif du
terme des cobayes pour voir comment
évolue aujourd'hui la recherche dans ces
domaines qui sont un peu bas du sien et
que le grand public découvre également
grâce à ce projet donc c'est un projet
là qui se déroulent tout au long de ce
semestre qui a commencé en janvier et
qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à l'été avec
des différentes communautés
[Musique]
c'est un campus récent qui s'étend sur
cinq hectares de l'apprenti à
l'ingénieur on y trouve toutes les
formations dédiées aux services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité motos
autos vélos on démontre on expérimente
on apprend tout de suite les précisions
de sabrina qu'aucun coup délégué
régional amf à ile de france
[Musique]
de ça
vous êtes sur le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité
véritable vitrine de la profession des
services de l'automobile le campus
ouvert ses portes en septembre 2018 et
il s'étend sur cinq hectares
douze mille mètres carrés de bâtiments
est quasiment de 1000 m² d'ateliers il
propose une offre de formation complète
du préapprentissage jusqu'au diplôme
d'ingénieur en passant par l'otc ap le
bac pro et le bts et la licence
professionnelle dans tous les domaines
aussi bien le domaine de la moto du vélo
de l'auto tant sur la partie commerce
que sur la partie maintenance le campus
peut accueillir jusqu'à 1000 personnes
c'est un véritable lieu de démonstration
d'expérimentation et de formation
plusieurs publics se croiser semaine
tous les jours puisque nous accueillons
à la fois des jeunes en alternance en
contrat d'apprentissage contrat de
professionnalisation des demandeurs
d'emploi en reconversion et des salariés
en formation continue
le campus illustre les attentes des
entreprises entreprises qui recrutent et
qui ont besoin d'un outil de formation
pour assurer la relève
former les futurs salariés de la branche
est fort mais également les salariés qui
sont en entreprise
[Musique]
l'objectif du campus bas c'est de
pouvoir promouvoir les métiers des
services de l'automobile pouvoir
renouveler la population salariée former
la relève et former les salariés qui
sont actuellement en entreprise et
répondre aux enjeux que les entreprises
doivent relever au défi que les
entreprises doivent relever aussi bien
technologique qu'écologique
[Musique]
non
oh
c'est le printemps que faire à paris
saclay voici une autre agenda
beaucoup d'événements sont prévus à
centrale supélec avec déjà 7 e rencontre
avec laurent nunet ce symposium reçoit
le secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'intérieur et ancien directeur de la
dgcis
c'est le mardi 9 avril à partir de 19
heures attention les inscriptions sont
obligatoires pour tous ceux et toutes
celles qui ne font pas partie de
l'établissement centrale supélec à
kye-ossi la prochaine édition de paris
saclay springs est le rendez vous de
l'innovation du territoire ce sera le 15
mai si vous voulez tout savoir sur
l'innovation bio inspirée
rendez-vous à l'edf lab paris saclay
pour assister à un colloque sur le sujet
léonard de vinci dont on célèbre le 2
mai le 500e anniversaire de la
disparition fut le pionnier dans ce
domaine
les tarifs vont de 100 euros à 30 euros
notre agenda culturel si vous aimez le
cirque moderne ne ratez pas le spectacle
ça déménage les élèves de le nsrs paris
saclay vous propose de les accompagner
dans leur déménagement imaginaire c'est
le vendredi 5 avril à partir de 19h30 ça
se passe à gif sur yvette et c'est
gratuit
de la musique avec l'orchestré
symphonique du campus c'est 70 musiciens
emmenés par martin barral célèbre
l'arrivée du printemps avec biz et saint
saëns brahms ce sera le samedi 11 mai à
20 heures à l'espace vasarely à anthony
et le dimanche 19 mai à 17 heures en
l'église du neubourg
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
pour rester informé notre site eps.fr et
bien sûr regardé tv 78 à très bientôt
[Musique]